You’ve probably heard a lot about tariffs
in the last couple of years.
But what are they, really?
And when countries impose them, who wins?
And who loses?
Tariffs are essentially a tax on anything
imported.
Businesses that buy foreign goods pay this
tax to their national governments.
For example, if the United States imposes
a tariff on goods from China, American companies
importing those goods must pay U.S. customs
to bring them in.
After that, a few things could happen.
The Chinese company might cut prices so potential
customers stay happy and keep buying their products.
But let’s say the Chinese company doesn’t
cut its prices.
In that case, the importing company in the United States might accept a smaller profit to keep its own customers happy.
But what typically happens is that businesses
pass some or all the costs of that tariff on to consumers.
So prices rise.
And the consumer ends up paying more for the
same product.
Or they just don’t buy the product at all.
But why do governments use tariffs in the
first place?
One reason is to try to protect or prop up
domestic industries that are losing out to imports
from foreign competitors.
Another is to retaliate against
unfair trade practices by foreign governments.
For most of the last century, tariffs fell
out of favor.
Much of the world came to see freer trade
as a benefit.
It boosted growth.
It expanded consumer choices.
It lowered retail prices.
The competition fostered and encouraged
innovation.
This made companies more efficient.
It also made them more profitable.
But, recently tariffs have surged back into
prominence as a favored tool of President Donald Trump.
He’s used them more than any president since
Herbert Hoover.
He has slapped them not only on China, but
also on U.S. allies like the European Union,
Mexico, and Canada.
These tariffs mean U.S. producers that import
materials or parts, they have to pay more.
That makes products more expensive.
And that leads to fewer sales and more job losses.
Tariffs also invite retaliation which has
led to reduced exports.
Take China.
The United States is China’s biggest trading
partner.
It imports more than half a trillion dollars
in goods every year.
As Americans buy iPhones, clothing, washing
machines, and much more.
But the U.S. also exports $120 billion dollars a year to China.
These are things like aircraft, machinery, and soybeans
that all head east.
So after President Trump imposed tariffs on $250 billion dollars worth of Chinese goods in 2018, China responded with tariffs on U.S. goods.
This led to a drop in U.S. exports to China.
Predictably, bilateral trade between the two
giants fell.
Partly as a result, trade and economic
growth are slowing worldwide.
Traditional trade patterns are shifting too.
U.S. companies are buying more clothes from
Vietnam and more smart phones from South Korea.
China is now getting more of its soybeans
from Brazil and Argentina.
And across the United States,
farm bankruptcies are on the rise.
In response, the U.S. government has pledged nearly $28 billion dollars in subsidies for American farmers.
That's about $7 billion more than the government is taking in from China tariffs.
So yes, tariffs offer a potent weapon
for countering unfair trade practices.
But tariffs also raise costs for local companies.
This leads to lower demand for their products,
it reduces their sales abroad, and costs jobs and profits.
It also unsettles global markets.
So, in the end, who pays for tariffs?
As we've seen, it's usually you, the consumer.